yeah well I as I said earlier on we
moved on from Newton so we no longer
think only in terms of just little bits
doing that thing and Hillary is already
mentioned how the idea of force and so
on was introduced by by Newton and those
forces nowadays we describe in terms of
what we call fields I think people know
have some sort of vague idea maybe of
what a electromagnetic field is they
don't want to be too close to a
microwave antenna maybe or a
gravitational field the earth goes
around the Sun because it feels the
gravitational field but now we go beyond
that and we see that you know to use
your term there is actually a sort do
allottee between particles and fields
and I already mentioned this earlier one
of the revolutions of quantum mechanics
is this dual description in terms of
fields and particles so it's certainly
true that our formulation of this
materialistic description has changed
over the last century and I would
presume that the description that we
currently have is also provisional it's
going to be out of date not quite sure
know when it's going to become out of
date but maybe it won't become out of
date because before I do but anyway I
just want to maybe pick up on one thing
which is this issue of consciousness and
mind so into the pond I talked to her
earlier one about emergent phenomena and
I personally believe I have no proof
that consciousness and mind will
eventually turn out to be emergent
phenomena from these physical processes
described by stuff on my t-shirt can I
can i pick up on that if you please do
yes lots of people very glibly say and
I'm not accusing you of that but lots of
people regularly say oh it's an emergent
phenomenon
you have cautiously said it will turn
out now if you think about emergence I
mean I think about something simple like
wetness emerging from the properties of
waters I mean it took a very long time
to work out why and to understand the
the physics and the chemistry to get
to understand I don't know surface
tension or whatever as emergent but
somehow mind I mean this is the whole
problem of mind-body dualism
it seems so utterly different from
physical things can you plot any kind of
a way that this you said eventually it
would turn out have you got any thoughts
about how it would turn out because
wouldn't that be fantastic if we could
see how this mind-body dualism could be
overcome by showing how it could emerge
you probably got the wrong person to try
to provide you with an answer to that no
this is not something which I work on
that I fought about at all deeply I
think actually we're now wait a very
interesting stage when this is actually
coming to the scientific forces so
people are thinking a lot now about
artificial intelligence about deep
learning and I think that out of that
will emerge all sorts of new intuition
about how these parts of the brain
function actually come about now whether
this will really get as far as what
you're interested in I don't know but I
think it is at least potentially an
inroad into how no emergent phenomena
occur inside our skulls
it's the emergence that I can't get I
mean what seems to me that the more we
learn about how the brain works
the more problematic consciousness is so
we can now look in brains and see oh
this person it's difficult and requires
a lot of stuff but and a lot of mass as
well but we can say that that person's
thinking about a pink elephant oh and
now he's thinking about a frog and now
he's thinking about last week in
wherever he was and you can actually see
this in individuals with a lot of prior
work so and we also know you know
decision-making going on here as I was
talking about the TPJ where the self
schema is is is constructed in the right
temporoparietal Junction we're learning
more and more and more so in terms of
what the brains doing in the structures
and how it gives rise to saying I am
thinking about the problem of emergence
we can get there but
the look of your lovely hair as I sit
here in its shining and allowing your
mutual adoration that's great that's
what we want on the panel um you know
that experience how that would emerge
what that would mean from it to emerge
that remained what becomes even more
problematic to me the more we understand
what the brain is doing
did you know that the Institute of arson
ideas also has a podcast philosophy for
our times brings you the biggest ideas
from the leading thinkers around the
world every week search for philosophy
for our times and subscribe today on
your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode